au lycée choiseul proviseur-adjoint
équipes enseignantes planche sur
l'aménagement des emplois du temps des
lycéens du pôle espoir concilier ses
études et le sport de haut niveau
un double projet essentiel et des
décisions difficiles à prendre pour tom
et alice déficients visuels tous les
deux dans les matières
comment s'est passé tom sur l'année
dernière qui était votre première des
deux années de terminale puisque vous
passez votre bac st2s en deux ans ma
première en l1 ne s'est rien passé parce
que brad et j'avais vu passer des
matières l'année dernière donc le
c'était thématique méthodologie m'as tu
vu surgir au sport j'avais dans ma tête
l'idée de faire une terminale comme
comme tout le monde et après demain à
l'aide de mandat et du lycée j'ai quand
même fini par choisir le bac sur deux
ans parce que c'était beaucoup plus
simple pour les entraînements extra pour
la fatigue je fatigue est assez vite et
je les ai bien vu en première j'ai
commencé à réfléchir tu peux je verrais
mal de séparer la ss et limmat
je veux c'est quelque chose qu'il a
quand même bien ensemble et cm2 plus
gros coeff
donc moi je réponds c'est dépassé cette
année d'accord et garder une des deux
langues vivantes 9 après 16 heures
depuis la loi sur le handicap de 2005
des enseignants référents accompagnent
les élèves porteurs de handicap en
milieu scolaire ordinaire
tom est suivi depuis le ce2 à l'iss
depuis la première notre rôle c'est un
peu d'être à la fois un lien entre la
famille les guider dans leurs démarches
auprès de la mdph les enseignants
éventuellement les conseiller sur les
adaptations pédagogiques et puis les
soignants aussi qui viennent eux apporté
leur savoir sur le handicap
et puis les
l'étang de soins qui les apportent sont
aussi à prendre en compte dans
l'établissement du de l'emploi du temps
comme tom alice est accompagné d'une
auxiliaire de vie scolaire pour certains
cours en sciences économiques et
sociales elle prend des notes à sa place
la guide quand le coup bêtement rapide
et ces cours sont d'ailleurs envoyé par
les professeurs d'alice sur sa tablette
une organisation bien rodée qui l'aident
à mieux se concentrer des cours ou et ça
demande énormément de concentration
parce que je fais tous mes cours à
l'oreille lac à partir du moment où je
lâche jeu j'ai plus de cours c'est pour
ça que l'avait assez importante aussi et
donc oui j'ai beaucoup de concentration
beaucoup de fatigue qui s'accumule plus
vite mais pas le choix genre littéraire
scolarité comme tout le monde et est
donc faut tenir et puis c'est pas grave
on s'habitue après les cours ce sera
l'heure du sport le premier entraînement
d'athlétisme est attendu avec impatience
par tous les athlètes du pôle espoir